you're going to tell us everything you
know
i'm not selling you a [ __ ]
you can electrocute him all day it'll
only make him angrier
i on the other hand will tell you
everything really
michael bryce was trying to put his past
behind him you need to forget
bodyguarding repeat after me no
bodyguarding no
then he got pulled back in let's go
jesus to protect this homicidal nut bags
wife what is he doing here i said get
anyone
but michael rice i believe it's
pronounced
thank you in four days
all of europe was burned they're
planning a full-scale cyber attack
do not scoop this up oh we are
definitely
gonna screw this up i promised my
therapist no bodyguarding let's not do
that guys let's just focus
i got it no it's fine you guys just you
guys have had him
maybe feather the break a bit i need you
to protect us
we're trying to have a baby
we gotta have mercy on ourselves now
repeat after me
i'm unlicensed i'm unlicensed that's
terrible
louder i'm unlicensed and i don't give
up
we need guns we need boats
we need them are you ready to get your
free con
what that came out wrong not together
with us that also came out wrong
now let's go do what we do and blow some
things up
i would make a great mother don't you i
think you're good
thank you it must be your powerful
asexuality that makes you such a good
listener
we just acknowledge that not only are we
safe this really feels like a
come
newbie
[Music]